back in September I counted down the
worst Disney animated movie villains now
thanks to your votes on my Twitter we
get to cover the best I'm Walter burn a
Z AK and this is top 5 with Disney
cember just ending I think it's safe to
say that the mouse house is still fresh
in all our minds and what is Disney
better known for than its roster of
iconic villains there are many great
antagonists that have given our heroes a
run for their money
across Disney's 80 plus years of
animated feature films we love to hate
them and a lot of the time they steal
the show while becoming the highlight of
their respective movies as expected this
list was far from a simple one to put
together I had a really tough time
choosing just five of these evildoers to
occupy the spots on today's countdown
everyone has their favorites and I think
the following bad guys are the best
that Disney has ever come out with these
are the top 5 best Disney animated movie
villains number 5 karela Deville from
101 Dalmatians karela Deville might be
the most appropriately named Disney
villain ever made she's an old school
friend of Anita whose dog Perdita just
gave birth to a litter of puppies she
wants to buy the pups so she can turn
them into a fur coat karela is obsessed
with fur and her obsession manifests
itself in her actions more and more as
the film goes on her signature look
attitude and theme song have made her
one of the most well known Disney
animated characters when I think Disney
villain karela is the first name that
comes to mind it's difficult to find a
more popular antagonist among these bad
guys it says it all in her song if she
doesn't scare you no evil thing will o2
seems to take a sudden chill crew
101 Dalmatians came out in 1961
that's some serious staying power years
before Disney was rebooting all of their
classic animated features into
live-action movies Glenn Close was
portraying karela in the 1996 101
Dalmatians remake her status as one of
Disney's top villains has never really
went she just oozes charismatic evil and
what's more evil than wanting to kill
puppies and wear them nothing that's
what
number 4 Ursula from The Little Mermaid
Ursula is a sea witch who has headed out
for Ariel's father King Triton for years
her ambition is to control the Seas as
its ruler her plan to do just that and
take down King Triton involves tricking
Ariel with a magically binding contract
which forces Triton to give in to her
demands
Ursula's design voice and flamboyant
demeanor have helped her persona last as
one of Disney's most iconic adversaries
I don't think there's a Disney villain
out there who loves being evil nearly as
much as Ursula she does some dastardly
things in the Little Mermaid and
thoroughly enjoys every single second of
them that's why she's so much fun she
may be the key to lightness between
life's full of tough choices in it
she's unapologetically wicked poor
unfortunate souls some syrup pretty well
[Music]
but on the whole to those poor
several times in the movie you can see
her dirty deeds on full display
like when she transforms into a young
human woman to gain the affection of
Prince Eric
and it's even better when she changes
back
she's got to deal with the devil gimmick
down and the climax involving her is
thrilling it still looks great and is
genuinely exciting don't ever turn your
back on this sick a Lea Ursula is as
evil as they come number three
judge Claude Frollo from The Hunchback
of Notre Dom frolo is a Parisian justice
minister who begrudgingly raised his
Quasimodo after he kills his mother he
is an especially cruel and evil man who
genuinely believed that every terrible
act he commits is permissible because
they are in the name of God he despises
the local gypsies and often tries to
wipe them out with his gang of soldiers
apparently celibate Frollo finds himself
lusting after the beautiful gypsy
Esmeralda and struggles deeply with this
to purge these feelings he sets out to
either convince Esmeralda to be with him
or kill her as a witch
Frollo is maybe the darkest Disney
villain they've made up to this point
his motivations are surprisingly mature
for a kids movie not unwelcome but
definitely a departure from the
run-of-the-mill Disney bad guy he seems
to love torturing people you know my
last captain of the guard was a bit of a
disappointment to me with my mentor she
he's also creepy as hell in this scene
with Esmeralda gypsies don't do well
inside stone walls
what are you doing I was just imagining
the rope around that beautiful name how
he treats Quasimodo and thinks that
other people are so far beneath him
shows just how dangerous he can be
especially when it comes to the gypsies
the highlight of the film is Frollo song
hell fire it depicts his lust
self-hatred and almost guilt for what he
feels inside it's a fascinating
character moment that stands out not
just in the movie but in all of Disney's
animated features
[Music]
[Applause]
we haven't seen the likes of Frollo
since the Hunchback of Notre Dame maybe
they thought this kind of character was
too mature for kids I might agree to a
certain extent but I think it will be
great to see our Disney Villains go in a
similar direction a little more often
number to scar from The Lion King
scar real name taça is the younger
brother of King Mufasa and uncle of
future King Simba his motivation to
overthrow his older brother as king is
made even more difficult by Simba who is
next in line for the throne his jealousy
is matched by his cunning intelligence
and charisma scar is an excellent
manipulator who also controls an army of
hyena that join him when he used SERPs
Mufasa is thrown at Pride Rock
he remains one of the most popular
villains and one of the most popular
films in Disney animated history who
doesn't love them some scar The Lion
King was a massive hit when it came out
in 1994 and scar was as big a part of
why as Simba or any other character in
the movie Jeremy Irons voice and
over-the-top yet bored delivery made
this black-maned lion one of the more
distinct Disney villain personalities
I'm surrounded by this is just for you
and your daddy you know a sort of
father-son thing
his familial tie with Mufasa and Simba
made his evil deeds even more
reprehensible one of the things I love
about his character is how he interacts
with Mufasa at the beginning of the
movie there's so much we didn't know
about the relationship but their history
with each other made both characters
deeper without having to do or see much
maybe the most iconic part of the Lion
King is a scar line
no leave that king
his manipulation of little Simba after
his father's death is also handled great
run run away and never return in
addition to all that he's really funny
it's a small world after all oh no
anything but that love scar I'm very
interested to see how they adapt him in
next year's new movies
[Music]
and the number one best disney animated
movie villain is Jafar from Aladdin
Jafar is the Royal vizier to the Sultan
of agrabuff who also doubles as a
sorcerer
he often hypnotizes the Sultan into
taking his suggestions and aims to rule
Agrabah with Princess Jasmine at his
side he is adept at convincingly
disguising himself to get what he wants
and is in search of the lamp so he could
control the genie and take over he finds
an unlikely enemy in Aladdin who he
despises as a street rat Jafar is a
widely popular animated antagonist who
will be in next year's remake of Aladdin
in live-action form Jafar is a master
manipulator he can get others to do his
bidding by several different means
while his snake staff might be the most
well known my personal favorite in the
movie is his old man disguise the letter
has two gold makes the rules we can't
talk about you far without talking about
Iago their banter is one of the best
parts of a lad only until she finds that
husband Jafar can be elegant goofy
dark and threatening throughout the film
he's a well rounded adversary for
Aladdin
and a very dangerous enemy as we get
toward the climax of the movie we see
[Music]
he's just awesome Jafar holds all the
qualities of a great villain in one of
Disney's greatest animated films in my
opinion he's the best of the bunch over
on my personal channel you can check out
an episode of the countdown continue
where I discuss and order the honorable
mentions from this list also a Jumanji
95 vs Jumanji 17 comparison video will
be going up soon so stop on by for more
content I want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite Disney
animated movie villain what do you want
me to cover next in the show leave a
comment and let me know to keep in touch
like my Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B and follow along on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future see
you next week on a brand new episode of
top 5
[Music]
you